now my socialist author grace blakely
conservative writer esther krakow
welcome to you ladies um
i just look at that picture grace
and
whether you support him or not a lot of
people who have done a thing that
tonight they begin to move their
position because it's so damning it's
clearly a party it's a leaving party for
his former spin dr lee kane you can see
there's a lot more than two people there
the prime ministers are drinking his
hand there's bottles all over the table
food all over the table that is a party
and just to remind everybody this was a
time when if you know people couldn't go
to funerals they couldn't go and see
loved ones in hospital
people were dying on their own because
of the rules set by that man who's
having a party he then told parliament
never happened
to answer louise's question which is why
would he do this if it was going to be
so you know career destroying for him it
is simply because he does not believe
that the rules apply to him as you said
he's been removed from many jobs before
he's been accused of lying he's been
accused of lying on you know multiple
different occasions because as someone
who was raised in the way in which he
was raised you know accustomed to being
able to move around society to move
around you know various different high
political institutions senior posts
without ever having anyone question his
right to be there he believes he
deserves to be prime minister he
believes he deserves to make the rules
to control the country to set the rules
for everyone else but that those rules
simply don't have a question for you
given your political allegiance but
there's a picture of kia stammer who's
the head of the labour party and he's
been under investigation for what
appears to be a not dissimilar situation
where he's having drinks for some of his
staff we know about this now my question
about this
is that despite all his denials
kierstama was very very very clear
that from the moment boris johnson was
investigated by the police kiyostama
said he should have stood down
why has the same rule not applied to kia
stammer now that he is being
investigated by the police well piers i
mean you know my political allegiances
and you know that i'm not the biggest
fan of kierstarma and i think to be
honest your labour i am labour but
you're hardly he's hoist himself by his
own pitard in this situation because he
has sought to present himself to the
country as you know this very um
righteous lawyer type who is going to go
in and kind of you know make sure that
the political class all obeys the rules
and believes that kind of presenting
himself as this stand-up character is
what's going to win the electorate over
now not only has that not worked because
he hasn't presented a compelling message
as to how he needs to change the country
he's obviously ended up in this
basically one-sided suicide pact where
he said to boris johnson you need to
step down and i'll step down and if i'm
found to break the rules so yes i mean
kia stamos also messed this up we're
suffering from a really severe death
political leadership in this country at
a time when people are literally
unable to totally agree this is a
crucial time of the country and this is
why this is also distracting but also
important about trust esther
can you put out any defense for this
you're a conservative absolutely and i
you know i voted for boris and but i've
also been i think you know in a country
that
actually if you want to see your country
progress you should be very open about
criticizing people regardless of whether
you're politically left or right i don't
think obviously kiyosama
and this beer cake beer gate is
justifiable but i think it's the same
thing for boris i think what's worse for
boris is it's clear one he lied but also
there's there's he didn't know the rules
that he set for himself right or for the
rest of the country and i think that's
what's more damning because i don't
think he had any compassion when he
actually looked at what he put the
country through in terms of telling
people not to be able to go to funerals
people not being able to see loved ones
so should he resign after this i mean if
the rest of the report when it comes out
the sugro report and i think it's very
murky they had this meeting and have
been and he's been lying about even
having the meeting whose idea it was but
if the report is has a load more
pictures like this and boris johnson's
involved in loads of these things should
he just one principle he should resign
but he won't right and i i think also
there should be should conservative mps
have a higher moral bar than they
currently should or mp should including
labour mps i think what i can what i'm
seeing here is a huge lack of humility
in our politics it's okay to say we got
it wrong you know this covert thing
happened everyone was scrambling for a
solution we clearly couldn't follow the
rules that we set for you so we don't
blame you for not being able to follow
those rules because we didn't follow
them ourselves it's not just about
morality though it's also about
accountability and this is actually a
problem that goes to the heart of our
politics we have this idea of
parliamentary sovereignty and it's very
difficult to really hold senior
politicians account to account for
anything historically if this had
happened to anyone else they would have
stepped down because there was a basic
sense of kind of you know honorable it's
really down to a 56 tory mps to decide
if this reaches their moral value
and you know what they know they know
that they don't have anyone else good
question before we let
just quickly ask you about wolf
whistling very interesting piece in the
times today by a female columnist uh
claire folgers which she talks about i
appreciate that
thank you thank you the i actually
didn't get wolfe's all day in the street
i was actually flattered but that's you
know it's different for me um
people won't believe you but it happened
um a woman actually almost crumbled but
it was it was
but let me ask you about wolf whistling
because the argument she put up was we
shouldn't be criminalizing wolf
whistling which is what is at the moment
uh going through as a potential new
legal bill is that we should make it
illegal to wolf whistle because it would
be harassing women in public
do you agree with it
i don't because i don't think we should
be criminalizing you know
much more stuff at all in fact i think
we criminalize far too much stuff and
actually if you look at the way that
this is enforced you know we know that
the metro metropolitan police has a
problem with institutional racism how is
this going to get enforced we see this
historically these rules particularly
around women are generally enforced on
certain populations when they're
directed to certain populations i can
imagine this ending up being something
like you know why does stop and search
happen it's when the police smell weed
and it's used as a way to criminalize
black people the same thing could happen
here with you know um ethnic minorities
wolf whistling towards white women and
being or even esthetic
whistling at men well exactly because i
i know their instances listen i know men
young men that have had their bums
grabbed by older women yeah i know women
um boy um young men that have had some
sort of what you would assume to be
sexual assault but in public by women
that think they can take liberties with
men because there's not that fear but
once it's a man doing it to a woman
because of these assumptions that it's
obviously vitriolic and horrible and
some sort of misogynistic violence then
that all of a sudden
is intent a key part of this and the
sense that i could imagine someone wolf
was thinking a very leering unpleasant
quite intimidating manner yeah and being
unpleasant with it or i could imagine a
bunch of cheeky young builders on the
building site wolf whistling in a cheeky
non-threatening manner and thinking it's
just a bit of fun isn't it if you if
you're attracted to the person wolf
whistling at you that's not harassment
if you find them unattractive and they
look like a toad that's suddenly
suddenly harassment it has to be an
aesthetic bar for the wallpaper
and the line obviously can't be whether
or not they're attractive the line has
to be where the behavior is consistently
threatening someone staring at you for a
really long time is following you around
and you feel scared that you should be
able to you know it is more than more
physically exactly that is something
that you should
yes if you wolf was sort of you would
you go to the police and be like oh the
horror well no i wouldn't go to the
police for anyone wolf whistling at me
but if they were like you know stalking
me you know i remember i remember
cindy crawford the supermodel told me
when she was 21 she walked down
knightsbridge dressed to the nines high
heels looking fantastic and the entire
street stopped cars stopped builders
thousands came out she was mobbed right
and then i interviewed her when she was
in mid-40s and she went i just walked
down the same street and nobody batted
my lid and she or what i give for a
builder shouting at me now
and that was cindy crawford yeah so i
don't know you can be careful what you
wish for but listen good debate nice to
see you both thank you very much